Contracts are understood and enforced as voluntary agreements between parties.
So when one party lacks volition,
the basis for enforcing the contract does not exist.
In today's lecture,
we talk about a party must have legal capacity in order to enter into a contract
under the common law.
Minors,
which are often called infants by the court do not have legal capacity to
contract.
In 1950 Ohio Court of Appeals Case David versus Cleland provides a stark example
of this doctrine in Davis.
The defendant's sold a car to a minor after crashing the car into a telephone
pole.
The minor sought to rescind the transaction and get his money back.
The court ruling for the minor reason that quote,
those who deal with a minor must do so charged with the knowledge of the
controlling principle of law,
which is here may work some injustice in individual cases,
but affords in general the protection of minors against their own improvidence
at a time when they are presumed to be incapable of protecting themselves
unquote.
In recent years,
courts and legislatures have diminished the protection from minors somewhat
even.
So miners still lack the full legal capacity to contract.
The rule that miners lack capacity to enter a contract is captured by section 14
of the restatement of contracts which reads unless the statute provides.
Otherwise,
a natural person has the capacity to incur only voidable contractual duties
until the beginning of the day before the person's 18th birthday.
In general,
uh,
minors contracts are voidable as opposed to void.
This means a minor can avoid his or her contractual obligations by timely and
appropriate disaffirm.
It's but the other party,
if an adult is bound,
the rule makes contracting with minors risky.
However,
once a minor reaches the age of majority,
the minor can ratify or affirm the contract.
Even adults may lack the capacity to contract if they're mentally incompetent.
Section 15 of the restatement provides a person incur is only voidable
contractual duties by entering into a transaction if by reason of mental illness
or defect.
A,
he's unable to understand in a reasonable manner the nature and consequences of
the transaction.
Or B,
he is unable to act in a reasonable manner in relation to the transaction and
the other party has reason to know of his condition.
Subsection two tells us that where the contract is made on fair terms and the
other party is without knowledge of the mental illness or defect.
The power of avoidance under subsection one terminates to the extent that the
contract has been so performed in whole or in part or the circumstances of so
changed that avoidance would be unjust.
In such a case,
a court may grant relief as justice requires as events by the relative length of
the restatement sections the defense of mental and competence for an adult,
it's more complicated than the defense of lack of capacity for a minor.
The defense of infancy may be available even though the other party has no
reason to suspect he was contracting with a minor,
but the defense of mental incompetence focuses upon both the condition of the
party seeking to avoid the contract and what the other party had.
Reason to know.
Subsection one B says that a contract is voidable if a person is unable to act
in a reasonable manner and relationship to the transaction and the other person
has reason to know if his condition,
but the reason to know condition is absent from subsection one a with regard to
when a person is unable to understand in a reasonable,
reasonable manner the nature and consequences of the transaction.
Subsection two is then triggered when the other party is without actual
knowledge,
but might include circumstances when there is reason to know.
Are these varying standards concerning what the other party knew or ought to
have known?
Do they make sense?
The restatements treatment of impairment by intoxication closely mirrors its
treatment of incapacity because of mental illness,
but limits void ability to circumstances where the other party had reason to
know of the intoxication.
So let's see if we can answer this quiz.
Ashley Sells Boris a car for the Kelley blue book price.
Bora suffers from a mental illness and is legally incompetent to contract.
Ashley does not know,
nor does she have any reason to know that Boris lacks a capacity to contract.
Boris later crashes the car and hotel phone pole and seeks to return the damage
car and get his money back.
Borris.
His attorney argues that since Boris is mentally and competent,
the contract is voidable and Boris may rescind the transaction.
Is Boris his attorney correct?
Probably not.
Under section to when the contract is made on fair terms and the other party
does not know that she is dealing with them mentally and competent person.
The contract may not be terminated under Section 15 one if the circumstances
have so changed that avoidance would be unjust.
Here Ashley Sold Boris the car at a fair price,
did not know that Boris was mentally ill and circumstances have certainly
changed.
The car is now severely damaged after being driven into a telephone pole.
It would probably be unjust to allow Boris to rescind the contract under these
changed circumstances.
So let's recap.
A person must have legal capacity to contract miners and individual vigils with
certain mental health or drug induced issues.
Lack capacity to contract and their contracts may be voidable.